il faudra plus que des souhaits des
pensées et des prières
de la terre
au vatican le pape dit prier pour que
les pleurs de la terre et des pauvres
soit entendu
si non loin de là que les leaders des
plus grandes économies du monde
tentaient d'aplanir leurs différends
dans la lutte contre les changements
climatiques
le prince charles leur rappelant que
l'avenir de l'humanité est en jeu audace
de fitch
pour s'entendre ils ont dû faire des
compromis le canada aurait voulu de du
langage plus fermes et plus ambitieuses
dans la lutte contre le changement
climatique avec d'autres pays qui le
voulaient aussi il n'y a pas de date
précise pour atteindre la
carboneutralité mais le groupe convient
qu'il est primordial d'y arriver d'ici
ou vers le milieu du siècle j'aurais
aimé un engagement plus ferme pour faire
comme le canada et se commettre à nette
zéro d'ici 2050 un engagement laisse
quand même penser qu'il est possible de
progresser selon cette
environnementalistes pour que le g20
arrive aujourd'hui à s'entendre sur
l'importance de garder l'objectif de 1.5
à portée de main
c'est quand même significatif
il était temps en fait de ces jeunes ce
wiimake day l'hôte du sommet avait bien
prévenu que les décisions prises aurait
un impact sur le sommet de glasgow je
pense que ce g20 a illustré les défis
qui nous attendent à la cop16 ce g20 a
été malgré les tensions malgré les
divergences qui peuvent apparaître et
qui que les négociations des dernières
jours parfois des dernières heures ont
pu confirmer a permis de recréer de la
convergence en vue de glasgow les pays
du g20 émette 80% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de la planète les
décisions prises ici pouvait donc
propulsé ou minet et la conférence sur
le climat qui s'amorce à glasgow avec
des résultats en demi teinte rien est
encore joué ici madeleine blé morin
radio-canada rome